in live now chair
right thank you well I'd like to welcome
members of the committee and all agree
to this one
uh meeting of the heart Biddeford Harbor
board 26th of January 2023
um first item on the agenda would be
apologies for absence while they're
running
yes thank you chair councilor James and
Mr hardaker
right
right thank you item two confirmation of
the minutes
uh page uh minutes of the 20th of
October
uh reading from the bottom Pages three
four
five
six
seven
eight
so are we happy that they be taking as a
true and correct record we have to go
through the formal vote I'm afraid
foreign
thank you so Sandra are you gonna take
them through
yes thank you
picks for
councilor Christie or
councilor bushby or
Mr Gibbs I would have stayed and I
wasn't there
thank you and Mr paddy
for
thank you chair that's four four and one
abstention
thank you
uh item three action list
Pages nine to eleven who's gonna take
this one
foreign
Kelly
sorry I haven't got it on my screen at
the moment no need unfortunately I was
trying to help out as well it's
impossible to put it on the screen on
the screen
no we don't have it available
right
I haven't got it either okay
who's who's got it I've got it on paper
you want me to read it Bob yes please or
take them one by one all right uh minute
number 98 the pilot boat
the Harbor Master to keep under review
if the harbor requires its own pilot
boat or would an option to hire a boat
be more viable
thank you Peter can I I'll answer that
straight away we're out in it this
morning uh servicing the day of Gloria
so yes very much so but thank you it's a
good I think it's still worthwhile
reviewing it every
um every meeting at the moment
but it's running away at the moment
she's running beautifully at the moment
I know that's uh I shouldn't say that
but so you never say that about running
machine we do
all right drive on Peter right uh uh
again it's under the pilot boat um the
Harbor Master confirmed that having just
done two brisk sets of pilot exemption
certificate runs the boat is being well
and truly used to be kept under review
same same again right and uh the last
one under the pilot boat the Harbor
Master provided a brief update and asked
that this be kept on the AL the action
list for continued monitoring which I
assume it will be yeah absolutely right
absolutely the next one possibly more
contentious more in policy
the Harbor Master to explore ways to
generate income through Moorings
and it goes on to say more in policy has
been approved and detailed and the
gender item is starting to implement
parts of the policy getting people to do
what they have signed up to
well can I come back to that in that in
the report because it's inevitably going
to come back up in my report regarding
certainly the Apple uh so the various
houseboats uh and and progress on that
front
yep fun
right
um
I'll go on then to trailer charge
to make a charge for those launching a
bank end slipway uh RH to speak to the
car parking manager every areas the
parking and purchase of tickets
I'm sure yes Joe spoke to them and uh
and Kelly dealt with it in more detail
but there is uh difficulties of charging
at that slipway so that can't be pressed
uh progressed due to the the machines
but they are looking at how that can be
happen I hope that can happen
foreign
list yes leave it there
is a an addendum to that it says K
Jarman confirmed she had spoken with
parking services and was awaiting a
response from s Macy regarding the
parking order
yeah chair Steve Macy is the car Parks
officer who Kelly spoke to
um he did advise me that the machines
that they've got at the moment can't
provide that facility
um but he's looking in how it can be
going forward whether it's a software
upgrade
um or something can be done
uh Bob can I ask a question
reference the trailer parking would it
would it not be a better way
um to tackle this to you know to
actually speak to the The Operators the
the users and get them to buy a a
reasonably priced season ticket
at least then they've got it there for
the season and they because the ones
that look the ones that use it a lot are
the ones that you know we want to Target
nobody's gonna buy a season ticket
we could obviously look at doing that
um
however obviously it's management
especially with bank and slipway the
difficulty you've got is that uh yeah
there's nobody actually down there um so
it would only really be monitored as and
when the parking attendants are passing
through because the slipway is actually
managed by parking and it would work
obviously better at church Fields um
possibly because the trailers are left
there for several periods of time
um at bank end
um it's it's not used as frequently
um but definitely possibly looking at
something for Apple door
I've got my hand up is that okay yes
certainly John drive on yeah I mean I
think it's a fairly simple issue in the
sense that um I I mean I've used both
worries and the easy solution is to buy
two parking tickets
um so then you've covered both the
vehicle and the trailer and any parking
attendant walking by or see two tickets
on the windscreen and I think it given
that the effort is being put in to make
sure the bank end slipway is clear
um which is a really valuable resource
locally
um I think that's that's a sort of
Fairly sensible Way Forward and I
naturally when I use the circle hey I
bought two tickets
yeah
would it need any change to parking
rules or some signage to say that
just signage I think
well it's exactly what happens in
appledore and it just simply says buy
two tickets
Sheriff I can come in I think it would
be uh there would have to be an
amendment to the parking regulations but
we can follow up with Steve Macy if
we're able to do that because I think
each car park has to be listed and
registered separate
so the church field machines already set
up for that and it is actually on the
boards down there that um if you are
bringing a trailer that you purchase two
tickets
um the ones down at the um Bank end car
park are not set up to do that as yet
and I did raise the question of whether
we could have them set up to do that
like the church Fields but um I was told
no
two different
when I'm told no the question is always
why
I think that goes back to work looking
at different machines
um for the car Parks down there um which
would have the functionality to do that
um and he was going to use it as an
argument as to why these would need to
be purchased
um so would they were waiting on the
decision as to whether they were going
to purchase upgraded machines
I'm sorry but I don't quite understand
why you need upgraded machines
absolutely two tickets
yeah when it's just simply a signage
issue yeah
agreement yeah
absolutely sure so I suggest that we go
back and uh I can go back along with
Kelly and uh ask what what is required
for that to happen I think that's the
best course of action
um so we truly understand that we did
challenge why and it was to do with the
actual machines the facilities on the
machines to be able to do that hi hi
if you would please Richard
yep
and leave it on the action list
please right we're on to any other
business uh land a busy our walk RH to
speak to a state's team to look at
safety issue listing of Paving slabs and
retaining wall collapsing making that
part of the area dangerous
um it then says RH confirmed he had
spoken with the Estates team and
confirmed they would look at all the
safety issues and make safe anything
required RH to continue to monitor
yep chair that was set with me again so
they they took a look at
um uh to see what needed anything he
needed doing and and take any
um work
um perhaps Mr puddy can confirm whether
that has happened or not
um I've had no feedback from the Estates
team to say anything different are there
any health and safety concerns
um no I haven't there's nothing happened
at the end the the knuckle at the end of
the wall that's for sure
but the and some of the paving slabs are
still lifting
okay I'll chase them again chair
yeah another walk Richard
Okay carry on Peter right well the uh
next to about the cafe van
um look at relocation of Cafe van
complaint email received from the Lundy
office to be circulated
I don't know if it has I can't remember
seeing it but
um and also find out in the Cathy Van's
license renewal is due
I stand for the harlemaster I think it's
it's now been removed for all I don't
know
yeah the trailer's certainly been
removed and it's gone it's gone away
um and before uh I don't the honest
answer is I don't know about the license
um we
you'd rather missed this one so we'll
need to just try and chase this up find
out what the next license is due and
when and then try and make sure that we
um come up with a proper Solution that's
satisfactory to Lundy Island as well as
I know that we discuss it and length as
to whether it will spare that
um
Cafe 22 got a a a a a fair you know a
preference what felt like preferential
treatments
um to be honest with you I I haven't
taken any got any further than that than
that I don't know if you've got any
regulation Bridget
um no not at the moment I know that uh
Nick was was looking at their license
um and I was going to work closely with
yourself and Kelly going forward for
next season along with the farmers
markets so the the nut the license was
to run from the 19th of August for two
months so it's expired so any any
further action now is going to require a
separate license and you're absolutely
right that's going to have to be
deconflicted with the farmer's market
and make sure that I I certainly seems
sensible for us to use that area to its
full extent as a revenue generating area
um we just need to make sure that
everybody is done fairly and everybody
nobody's disadvantaged by it
and I just point out Bob that um they
did apply to the Town Council to put
their van on the port Memorial and we
said no
quite right too
I wouldn't think it went too long
discussing that chair councilor bushby's
got his hand raised yes councilor
Bushman
Doug you're muted
yeah thank you sir it's not a question
of
um of anyone getting preferential
treatment it's just the fact that they
are the only ones to my knowledge that
have actually you know asked courage
yeah that are very they're the only
company that have asked to actually cite
a van anywhere um on the keysight so
um no doubt they will be coming back
with another further request for this
this summer season to to sight the van
somewhere along there again sorry the
trailer you're absolutely right and what
we do need to do is make sure we do we
try and
um
get on the front foot this time rather
than last last year we were we were a
bit catching up and it was all happening
rather late so because it was It was
kind of um to deliver quite nice and
late notice you're absolutely right it
needs to be done fairly and absolutely
well you're right if they're the owner's
asking no then the only one's going to
get it aren't they yeah
okay thank you
I would suggest you need to get on it no
because they'll want to be open by
Easter why why
um I I take take advice the the board's
advice about whether we should just
actually go and prompt them or whether
we should wait for them to ask
I would suggest you wait for them to ask
yeah okay will do
as long as everybody's happy with that
yeah happy with that but they need to
understand that it will take a little
while to distrust around it to where
they go exactly exactly
won't happen in five minutes it's not
one person's decision no
yes okay drive on Peter this is the last
item
um
report reappador Moorings added to CNR
agenda to the fifth of December meeting
and I haven't had an output from the CR
meeting I I know it went there but I
don't uh I I don't know what what
happened
there's three of us who went to the
meeting I can't remember what happened
decision was taken actually to not
actually put it on ninja but to to look
in more detail and get more information
regarding Apple door
um and the activities that are going on
there and to do some due diligence
behind the scenes
um on the legality of the northern Claws
and their actual status of airport
yeah so I think that that needs to
remain there and we can report back
um to this committee
um in the next cycle
yeah so Apple door does need looking at
because you remember the rumpus about uh
all the professional and objected to the
charity going on Apple tour well I've
made a few gentle in quite a reason to
find that there's actually only one
fishing boat needed and object
foreign
I suspect this is probably going to come
up in my report as well because of
course it's now uh the Apple door on the
clean Maritime
um Innovation Center has suddenly
brought Apple doors very much to the
front front of the uh of the attention
queue
um and that um having that all
underpinned by a proper Harbor Authority
is probably going to be something that
is almost inevitable which will solved
with that problem itself but that
probably probably one for another time
okay Mr putty would like to come in yes
please yeah okay I mean I think they're
more than one issue here and um I did
report to Paul that just across here on
the the bank is um an abandoned boat
which I believe could cause a hazard to
uh incoming vessels because it's right
in the channel
or right on the edge of the channel so I
mean I think some control really is
important
um if only to preserve the access to the
port
John can I can I can I respond directly
that you you are um notwithstanding the
fact that the the port of Biddeford
effectively stops at the new bridge
uh and anything down it's not strictly
like that but anything Downstream of
that is not on our jurisdiction the ACT
our act does entitle and Empower us and
in fact um puts a burden on us to
maintain the safety of navigation up to
Biddeford and and down from Biddeford so
um please so my lack of response to the
to the small boat there wasn't the fact
that we weren't going to do anything
about it we are going to do something
about it it will be moved
um because I have a response you know we
have a uh a an obligation to do
something about that wider than that in
terms of addressing Moorings looking at
addressing your particular issue with
this for the fresh spring uh and the
open port Duty and running Apple door as
uh correctly or as it conventionally as
every other port in the UK's run is a
slightly bigger question you're
absolutely right there are there are
different layers here all of which
probably would be addressed by finding a
a properly constituted Harbor Authority
for Apple door but unfortunately the
answer to that is a harbor an Acton or a
harm or a vision order which is quite an
expensive Beast
um however it may very well be that we
we're actually going to have to do that
in due course with the LEP luf money
coming through
should this fact be conveyed across to
our officers dealing with the maritime
job absolutely absolutely it should
um oh well I've I sat at um the tour and
torridge uh SG Forum with Chris Fuller
uh about this and
um about 10 minutes after the
announcement came I emailed him to say
exactly almost exactly what I just said
um it's it's something probably what one
we're not going to solve today but
certainly I I was going to ask for the
harbor boards guidance on this to say
you know I I feel very strongly about
this I think it we really ought to do
something about it
um but whether we whether we just allow
this to happen as a matter of course
um as we go through in the next few few
uh months as the money comes online or
whether we we take the front foot on
doing on trying to resolve it I don't
know I'd be I'd welcome your thoughts
about how we should deal with this
foreign
yes come in
so I think uh this needs to be raised
obviously Sean is aware of the situation
um and I can raise it when I meet with
them next week in the manager's meeting
and discuss but you know it's not on our
forward plan at the moment to to look at
this yes there are things that need to
be done but likewise
um there's considerable expense
you know in code of which if the cancer
decides to do that
um without being forced to do it if it's
kind of decides to do that then members
will have to make that decision where
the money comes from
uh and what net gain there is out of it
so I'll raise it uh with Sean who no
doubt would speak with the chief
executive
I think we need to because now is when
they're playing around without a
maritime job I mean absolutely buried
into them that would be the time to do
it
absolutely
Mr Paddy would like to come in yes
please yes all I was going to say is I
think it given the leveling up funding
that's just been achieved and the
location it's absolutely critical to be
going through some process to ensure
that that um area of the river is
managed
agreed I agree I don't care if I can
come back in again I'm sure when the bid
went forward for the leveling up fund
the maritime Innovation Center
um it wasn't just a figure that was
allocated it would have been had to the
bid would have gone in and the money
would have had to have been allocated
for
the project itself no
if we're looking at potentially anywhere
between 50 to 100 then I'm not sure
there'll be that spare money but I will
raise this like I said with with Sean uh
and and speak with this
Steve and David Hayes
I agree I agree with all your points but
likewise we need to plan for these
things and the decision needs to be made
by TDC members potentially as this is
what they would like to do
uh yep
Richard the the answer to your question
uh that the email I sent through to
Chris Fuller was exactly that that the
the money for the luf although none of
that is allocated to resolving you know
historical uh Marine management issues
or anything else like that so anything
that we spent on resolving that would
need to be in addition and you know I
know a a a a business case put forward
for it
um because it'll be one you're actually
right it's one and separate foreign
Mr Gibbs would like to come in yeah I
mean surely this has been the the
importance of this must be flagged up
now before it's too late yeah 100
yep
uh Doug you're quiet Peter you're quiet
try not to get involved in apple door
stuff
[Laughter]
foreign okay
right move on
we've finished the action list now three
yeah sure sorry we've lost the
presentations we've lost the Wi-Fi in
our office so
um have you got a paper agenda in front
of you no I haven't okay so item Four's
public contributions we don't have any
um item five is agreements between Parts
one and two we don't have any
um item six surgeon Matters from the
chair
um
item seven is Portland Harbor accounts
from Paul
was it Richard yeah this would be me
thank you chair is everybody as we can
see up on the screen has everybody got a
copy
no struggling but don't worry yeah
that's okay so uh oh I just came to the
bushby raised last time at her local
Authority uh present their accounts is
somewhat different to uh private sector
we've tried to streamline it to make it
simpler so anything that is over budget
um at this period which is the end of
31st of December 2022 which is under
quarter three is in red green obviously
is is
um generating more income
so for the harbor
um section and we still run it in the
two Harbor and pilotage which does
confuse in Olympics there's a lot of
joint working that goes on there but
obviously
um you can see that the employees is
over at the end of quarter three and
four-year-old cast will be
um will be uh 11 000 over for salaries
and the main reason for that is when I
set the budget in November 2021
um the full restructure of Kelly and
Paul's positions haven't been
um weren't included in November because
they came through in the early part of
um but that said we've also as you can
see the subsistence budget is uh from
the old Harbor Master who used to come
up and stay
um it has been reduced significantly
um because it's no longer required
um we've also which is the same which we
have recorded two
um we had to have The Incident
Management uh for the port facility
security plan which was five thousand
and also additional crane repairs
um which which puts us over a three
thousand and then we had the higher of
the diesel pump to pump out the sinking
boat in apple door
um and I'm sure Paul is still called
about that as our responsibility but
he'll go into more details and that was
at two thousand pounds one good thing
about the harbor is um Mooring annual
Moorings have gone up by six thousand
um but sadly due to the lack of
um clay boats the operations and income
from the harbor operations such as the
crane and
um warfish and everything is down by
nine thousand so
we're looking at the actual Harbor
itself over a projected budget is 17 000
over this this as this quarter and that
would be the year out turn that's how it
looks but likewise I've explained 16 of
that was in The Incident Management and
the
um the additional salaries
so Peter do you want to sorry Peter's
got his hand up 200
can I come in there yes yeah I Look to
tell you but I can understand
the figures in
rather sort of overspend aren't they
is that right
yeah they are they are the overspend at
this quarter yeah well the figures in
red are the full year variants so that's
what we're projecting towards
um towards the end of four to four for a
whole whole year
all right I'm just going to ask the
harbor operations what's that the
seventh line down
that goes down yeah shown as red but
you're saying that's going to be the
whole year it's gone from 21 953 to 11
850 you know shown as a overspend of ten
thousand
yeah but that was actually the income
that's meant to be actually where the
income is coming in so the expected
income for our operations is down
so expenditure total is above below that
it should there is that's that's income
yep
so you've got General annual so you've
got if you just look at the grade line
expenditure total
then below those two lines which is
genuine or Moines and harbor operations
that's income
right sorry you've lost me but I'm sure
it's correct
okay so if you look at employees
premises transports supplies and
services and services by private
contractor
that is all expenditure directly to the
harbor then you have a grade line which
is their expenditure total that is all
of those added up man that gives you
your figure
then you have the general annual
Moorings and harbor operations
that is income
yeah
for Harbor operations we projected uh
this this
um
This this term we for the full year 20
nearly 22 000 income from Harbor
operations which is the use of the crane
pertan Conservancy
um everything else income that we charge
people that come to mainly the clay
boats
um and out of the ships that visit
due to the lack of clay boats we're
projecting that we'll we'll only be
receiving income on Harbor operations of
15 800 which is nine thousand down which
is why it's in red than we projected at
the beginning of the year if we'd have
more play boats and that will reduce
um we're hoping if we have more clay
boats um Paul go into that into his
report
um then
um that figure will reduce and hopefully
we can generate more income
thank you
not much more to say than that yeah
um then we go on to the pilot Edge
um and unfortunately as one is affected
negatively which we've just gone into
with other operations being down
without the pilotage for seeing in the
clay boats we don't have the staff
salary so you can see there that the
Staffing salaries for the pilot crew is
under budget to the sum of fourteen
thousand
um so for pilotage expense
um literally there is some lagging
figures that are coming in regarding
fuel that's always slightly down for if
there's any in the
um late on in in quarter three is
fourteen thousand under budget which
obviously it's unfortunate we wish it
was on par because that would generate
us more income
but then we have
income for for the apologies we've had
the uh additional one Yellen pilotage
which Paul will go into with the deal
Gloria had a campaign uh and the pilot
exemption certificate qualification
support was just done again now so we've
had you know a big yield for charging
them the rate for coming in
um to the to the Estuary and that's at
17 000.
um we've also
um they're benefited an applicable
pilotage like we said the politics is
down so that nearly Nets that off at 14.
so the income is five thousand
um
for income total so we're actually 20
000 under for for for the actual
pilotage and we've generated more
by doing less regarding the pilotage for
the Sam campaign in Paul and I and Kelly
talked about this earlier we generate a
lot from when the uh Australis and the
deal Gloria come in and do the campaigns
on top of this we've also got
um through raising the invoices right
Kelly has just raised another invoice
um for the Oldenburg for last for last
year so that will come in at an
additional 4 000. and Paul this morning
has been out on the sea once again
where he likes to be
um certifying the Dio Gloria Pilots
and they're having another campaign at
this moment which will generate another
seven thousand so
I'm hoping next year was this year's a
little bit skewed with our reporting
because of the restructure and the
establishment if all things remain as
they are at the end of quarter three now
um and the trade picks up the Harbor's
looking better than it's been if trade
doesn't pick up
um and Paul and Kelly are trying
everybody
um to to generate more commercial
operations in the harbor
um then you know things are looking okay
for the harbor it's still an expense but
our plan is always to make it cost
neutral
uh before we look at
not a very positive
um alternative
any questions sure
throw them to the floor chair Mr Paddy's
got his hand raised right Mr Buddy yeah
um well I I first of all I I there was a
discussion around and I can't remember
the correct terminology but I think it
was sort of chicken droppings or
something that Paul was looking into
um the second thing is
the revenue from the sand that's being
dredged from the torrid as we speak not
quite as we speak but is that going via
the harbor
uh accounts or is that a straight to
torrage
do you mean Jimmy
do you mean the sand from uh the one
that we're dredging off the shipyard
using the small dredger exactly
yeah it's uh that that's going directly
into the harbor accounts
um it's not very much at the moment
because they're still just starting so
they've they've judged 480 tons
excuse me so we've got 480 quid going
into the covers it's obviously not
showing in these these accounts but um
that that's good it is we are getting
that in John and it's poultry Ash you
were talking about but the more of that
in my report okay
um can I just ask one more thing
um I this may be a controversial point
but I I can I assume that the kyber does
not pay for the parking spaces that are
not in use while ships are birthing
uh so when when we shut the car park off
do we pay for the car park no we don't
no we don't well no I mean there's two
things here one is that for example if
we put on an event such as the Water
festival we pay 12 pounds for every
parking space that we use along the um
within the harbor boundary
um and as does any other event that's
put on in Biddeford
so there are two things here is one is
why is that Revenue not going into the
harbor coffers given that it's the
harbor of property
um and two it's also detrimental to the
local economy to be charging Charities
for putting on events in the town
thank you or you answer a call if you
wish I'll answer the first one John um I
I I promise you uh members of the board
I did not um tea John up to ask that
question
um the the answer is uh very well there
are many thoughts that have gone to
exactly this conversation whereby but
bits of the harbor Port estate are
rented out for car parking in particular
and then the parent organization has
then taken the income from that
um I haven't yet got to the point where
I I'm feeling brave enough to challenge
Torres to say actually the income from
the car park outside my office here uh
or indeed in the other carbox that lie
on Harbor land that the income should go
to the harbor Authority
um because we've not yet got to the
point where the conversation is being
had to say well actually we're going to
shut the port
um so while
torridge continues to bankroll as a bit
of a crude way of putting but continues
to provide the um the funds to keep Port
running there's there's no point having
that argument if we ever got to the
point where Torres District Council said
it's a bit of an Harbor you're not a
commercial organization anymore we're
going to need to shut you down then I
think we probably have that conversation
then but at the moment I don't think
there's any point in doing it because
it's just robbing you know it's just
transferring can't get the money
internally
um the second part about uh about
charging Charities I can't really speak
to but um I only but that you you can
see the accounts yourself to say that we
we need as any money we can possibly get
uh it would be my answer I've I've defer
to Richard on on those would you do
anything to add Richard
yeah I'll just come in to John's Point
um because I know came from Christy
wants in but yeah ultimately Tori Jersey
Harbor Authority it is land we are all
the same company you know we we do not
run at a profit that we can fund away
certain money the harbor is a cost to
torrage yeah therefore
um is it whether
the the harbor as we're running into
negative if the if the harbor generates
if the car parking on the keysight
generates x amount and the the
um Harbor itself is expected to
contribute to that where is the money
coming from it's coming from torrage so
it's it's volunteered to PayPal and it's
all very similar regarding the the the
events and and uh private sectors
wanting to have festivities and
activities even Community or not on
tourage land is I would have thought
Fernando a standard across any business
model if there is a net loss to the
authority and likewise
okay so the authority is in its right
and I don't know that it is a detriment
to to any of the Charities
um but I can definitely raise that once
again with Sean
um and the Estates team when we meet
next week
In fairness I can confirm that I have
niggled this more than once
in many respects it's an accountancy
thing yeah you know which account it
goes into at the end of the day at
Costco it's the same
uh and of course
it's no good to sort of say we'll use it
as an argument when they come to Super
Harbor because their comment would be
well if we shut the harbor we got more
parking space
yeah fair enough
um
yeah I've never felt it right but I've
niggled and got nowhere how do you feel
better
well I'm with you and that uh we have
raises on many occasions uh if Paul
wants to go back and read our minutes
for about 15 years ago he will see that
it was brought up then when the key was
widened uh this was an issue and if you
look at the 1928 actor which I think
it's that one
you know the harbor board is meant to be
an arms length thing and the money is
meant to go to the hardboard actually
but as you say toridge argued well we've
spent the money on it uh therefore we're
going to take it having said that uh on
Monday at CNR we were discussing whether
uh the taxis should be allowed
to sit on the key on a concrete plant
right next to the river there's a sort
of over spilled taxing rate and never
ever has anyone mentioned charging the
taxis for using the key
there so you know torrage isn't it's got
it seems to have different uh approaches
for different people uh you know they're
not going to charge a commercial body
like taxi but they will charge Charities
seem very odd but there are
um I I totally agree about I I I don't
strongly feel that we should be
approaching porridge to ask uh if were
we struggling to maintain the structure
of the port or need the money for a new
Crane or
um or or not being given money to
service the pilot vote if I was
struggling to you know having to go cap
in hand to Richard for uh money to keep
the port structure running then I think
it will be a different core but you're
absolutely right at the moment we're all
one and we're the one company so it
doesn't make much sense to try and to do
that uh as it stands
but I mean I'm grateful to know that
it's not just me that their conversation
has been had before
not they didn't necessarily got anywhere
though but there we go
Doug you got any comment
yeah thank you chair well well it's
actually I'm glad that John raised the
point actually because up until now I
haven't really thought too much about it
but the um the issue of
charging the Charities
um it's very interesting because I had a
meeting only uh last week with uh
the members from the soapbox Challenge
and the the Water festival in Sean's
office with Sean Carney
um we went through it you know in great
detail uh and you know that there's no
um there's no exception they they have
to pay for the for the area that they
use uh and it's interesting when you
consider what John just said because you
know
say take the bike show or the or the um
the Water festival they have one day use
of that facility and they have to pay
for the loss of car parking and yet the
if you've got a ship coming sometimes
it's it's at least three days you know
because it shot way before the ship
comes in and then all the time that it's
been loaded uh and as obviously then
there's a loss of car parking that never
gets mentioned by by torrage so you know
it it does seem like a bit of double
standards but
um as Richard says it's it's told just
corporate their loss so you know they
will try and recover any monies were
they you know where they can and you
know I'll have to say I don't blame them
for that but uh it does you know it does
seem a bit unfair when dealing with
local groups that you know are trying to
raise funds for charity we're the whole
tone benefits and I I did make the point
to Sean that I would much prefer for
torridge to be you know to to become
sort of a partner so that's a you know
it's it's a joint venture as long as
College get to do recognition that they
are equally as important as the round
table or any other organizations
I'm afraid of fellow deaf ears
right well we've seen those do we have
to move them yeah we've got a few more
hands from Tim Gibbs John puddy and
councilor Pennington right John putty
well no I was allowed to put my hand up
please
okay well all I was going to say is to
command Doug on what he was saying
because I think a partnership would be
absolutely tremendous where everyone
benefits because equally you know there
are events in Victoria Park
um all around the town that really do
make a huge impact on the local economy
and I think the other point perhaps is
that
people aren't going to disappear because
the key car parking isn't there they're
just going to Simply park somewhere else
in the town and pay the money anyway
thank you councilor Pennington on Donald
thank you chair for allowing me
non-committee member simple question on
a daily basis what earns more car
parking or Harbor charges
I see I I see the uh
um graph in front of us so it begs the
question can we stop doing the harbor
should I come into that
so over the three days there is a loss
you know I think as well we're
detracting from the harbor board Arena
to a degree if a recommendation wants to
go which storage members or members of
the hoverboard can do but this isn't a
decision of where the money comes into
whether the harbor accounts or whether
it goes to the torrid central port
that's a decision for CNR I would
suggest
um but likewise during the the period
that the boat is the clay boat is in for
those three days and it does generate
more but we also have a statutory
obligation to accept vessels
um therefore if cancer abundant a
recommendation comes through that we
should look at a harbor closure order
then that's quite an expensive lengthy
and I would say not popular
um decision to take but if that's what
members want to do we can certainly look
at it okay so I think that's quite
that's quite drastic and separate and at
the end of it uh I'd make it very clear
that
George still would or would not then
charge
um charities
I'm still linking the two issues
together because I thought the two
previous speakers called accidentally
about the charity issue
um it's just purely you're the best
opportunity for torrage but if we have a
statutory responsibility it's a
statutory responsibility like hosting
unfortunately we have to meet the cost
so we we are then put into a position
that we've got to make the best of the
position we're in so I leave it to you
officers but I should ask more from
central government if it's a statutory
responsibility we have to fulfill but we
probably get no money from central
government anyway no we we don't we're
covered by an act of Parliament
the Biddeford Harbor act or whatever it
is and said about when it comes in
produces several thousand how much would
it gross for
each boat uh each oh each profit each
each vessel well in percent of profit
will profit ten thousand pounds or so
per vote so if we if we wanted some the
figure that would uh mate the harbor
break even or or start to make a profit
is six clay ships a year normally on the
normal year we have four or five last
year we had three
um and more of this in my report but um
so while last year was a particularly
sparse year
um uh we're doing everything we can to
try and change that around so that this
conversation becomes null and void if we
get six ship if we can get six ships a
year because then a hardware Authority
then pays for itself and then uh
contributes overall to the storage uh
basket
okay thank you chair
right anyone else wishing to speak
I can't see the hands up chair Mr Gibbs
right
I've been involved with three other
hoverboards Municipal hoverboards and
this exactly the same argument every
time
it is it goes round and round and round
it's not the same pot basically it's not
really a useful argument while it's the
same pot exactly exactly exactly that
thank you I think we can move on to the
next item that's good
share that support and harbor activity
report
uh good afternoon everybody I'll be
quick because I think we've probably
covered quite a lot of what what I was
going to say anyway
um you can see from my report
um this quarter last quarter from
October through to as we're sitting here
now it's been a very quiet quarter no
ships have come into uh requiring
policies who've come into the Estuary
um in their reporting period none into
bideford and as I was just saying
um normally of a year we'd expect to see
four or five ships a year uh my goal if
I can if I leave as Harbor Master in
five or how many years time and we've
got sick we got six ships a year coming
in as a regular uh regular basis one
every two months
um then I would consider I could
consider what we're doing a success
Kelly and I have spent quite a lot of
our time talking to sibelco Pike Ward
and any uh a number Corey brothers and a
number of other shipping agents to try
and explore every possible option we can
to bring vessels into the in it's an
arbor recall at the last meeting I was
we were talking Corey Brothers we're
talking about poultry Ash
um bringing in uh they sent an agent up
here we talked it through we got very
excited about it and now I keep the
email I email them every couple of weeks
to say hey guys what's going on uh and
not the answer is not much at the moment
so the trouble is with shipping is it
tends to be quite un well unpredictable
when we get to our level of the market
if you're dealing with you know
um 10 000 cars coming from Japan every
two months and it's reasonably to
predict the where we are in the market
it's quite difficult to predict if we
can tempt sibelco to commit to six ships
a year uh then things start to look a
bit better
um I'm all right to move on from
Biddeford and Clay boats um we are I
hope
Mr Gibbs
um I think it's on the same subject it
may be of interest to you I'm having
dinner with the managing director of
handsome Marine on the 14th of February
oh yes please
could you ask him what he's doing with
his straight edge key down at uh
exactly yes please do I will be I've
been trying to get hold of somebody to
say you know we we ought to bring this
back at you yes please okay smashing uh
moving on to Apple door then uh we but
we best talk about the Bristol Giant and
the large crane which was at middle dock
uh in the storms in December she she
pulled her Moorings out at middle dot
middle dock is uh a subject a separate
subject
um and now she's moored in uh using her
own mud Moorings uh just south south of
the um
uh south of the shipyard now there was a
fair bit of a conversation going on
since then about whether we can or
should ask it to move is it derelict the
answer is no it's not direct it's a
working working uh barge it's not very
pretty but um it lies outside torrent
just uh sorry Biddeford Harbor's
statutory Authority area so I palack the
authorities the Harbor Master to direct
its movements we own the fundus but
we've yet as the Torres District Council
owned that own the fundus or we've yet
to to get to the point where we're
torrage are uh consider it the right
move to say this is our fundus Move Your
Vessel because if we do that we need to
do that every other vessel on our fundus
and I don't think there's an appetite
Entourage to do that and that's well and
truly outside my remit uh but you should
you should be aware that that's the
reason why nothing's being done about it
um
that's an apple door I guess we probably
ought to talk about middle door middle
Dock and the Lu uh luf funding
um super excited obviously Kelly and I
are involved because we're the the
nearest anybody anybody in tourist can
get to a marine expert so we've been
involved talking to Exeter University
and various other people about what it
is that might happen at Apple door
um if you ask me what it looks like I've
no idea but I know it's super exciting
and it can only be good for us the river
uh to bring development to that to the
river but I I know I don't need to say
any more about that
um if if you're happy to move on uh
yelland uh well of course my I wrote
this about 10 days ago and then uh day
of Gloria showed up uh I'm the reason
I'm looking like a bit like a scarecrow
and a bit gray around the edges because
I was up at 4 30 this morning
um riding with the dredger certificating
one of their mates uh that'll generate
another uh nine eight thousand pounds uh
in in fees as she's going in and out
over the next week or so and we expect
her to come back in May for a Top-Up
campaign there as well which will also
help
um dredging I've mentioned it Mr uh
seven series have been using their very
small directions or I pair in to uh take
the tops off the mud Banks down up there
or sorry the sandbanks down at um
um off the shipyard using our Authority
Under the 1925 bidified act to maintain
the uh the uh freedom of navigation
through to Biddeford to make sure that
that um Channel makes clear so that when
this clay boat
does appear hopefully next week next
month
um we've got enough water to get it in
and out without having to cut cargo
um we've earned the defensively sum of
480 pounds so far from from then
dredging at a pound a ton
um it's my intention to keep them doing
that to maintain it's generating a small
but significant bit of income uh it's
river sand and we are allowed we are
committed to do that within our Harbor
legislation provided we are maintaining
the uh uh the navigational Channel if we
start then dredging you know willy-nilly
in the river that's a different ball
game entirely and that's capital
dredging and we need a license for it
this is maintaining the river the river
Channel
um right gosh well I've spoken about
pikeball and sabelco bless them
um I you'll all get an email if we get a
boat coming up I will shall be shouting
from the rooftops as soon as we can Cory
breath and Corey brothers and poultry
action I've spoken to already William
shipping
um uh I tried I'll keep trying
um and if I get Hansen's to the table
that would be an absolute smashing major
bonus
Kelly is sending emails to the squirty
fountains company every year every other
week at the moment to try and say come
on at least give us a price but they
took they took the motherboard away
we've heard nothing since is that
correct Kelly yeah
um we'll keep pressing uh it would be
really nice to get Squishy fountains
working or at least understand what it
required to get them going again
um happy so far and very last but by no
means least uh Kelly and I attended the
tour and torridge Estuary Forum uh the
inaugural or really inaugural meeting of
of that about 10 days ago
um in the depths of Remington I think it
was
um there are lots of people who none of
whom I recognize all who had very dearly
held uh and very strongly held opinions
about the tour and the torrage about
what should be happening there
um and I put my head above the parrot
bit to say I'm the Harvest of bideford
and
um three hours later they I I got quite
a lot of that which which was fine
that's fine I went there to say uh we're
here the the the heart at least this
part the bs3 is listening uh could this
be the Harvard users group my my answer
was actually no they've got such a wide
remit from Barnstable to baggy point to
Westward Ho It's not really useful as a
harbor users group thus I thought
preempting this I'd say I think will
I'll start our own Harbor user group
with your approval all police board on
those terms as written down there to say
this is what I'd like to do I'd like one
of you to come along to each meeting to
provide me one week backup but also a
bit of uh Verity to to the board to say
I went to the meeting too to listen to
because I've absolutely no doubt it's
going to each one of these is going to
be up spirited I will choose who we
invite but try and make sure we've got a
uh a good spectrum of people to
represent what what happens in the
harbor
um but but I guess before I ask for
approval
um Mr Christie
yeah can I just ask at the
um Forum did the issue of the uh boats
along the Christie estate land
along the Estuary did that come up
because we did have a meeting a few
years ago the environment agency and
they were going to do something about it
but nothing happened it did and I I
baited them
four times during the meeting to say
because they said well at the moment the
tour as the S3 forums policy is that we
don't say no we don't discourage them
and I said well you know from from a bit
of at Harbor's point of view and
toridge's point of view
um we would actually be very grateful if
the S3 Forum would not encourage them
um uh at which point I said I asked them
four times during the meeting and they
that none of them picked up on it
um so yes it came up will they do
anything about it I don't it's with the
greatest respect to them and I got a lot
of respect for their opinions held there
but it's not a decision-making Forum
it's a consultation Forum
um that so unfortunately nothing will
come of it I think
hmm
I'm disappointed to say
consultation forum is a nice way of
seeing a talking shop
I've busted
um so uh I'm very keen to make sure the
harbor users group doesn't become a
consultation Forum it's we are we are
obliged to have a forum whereby people
users of the harbor can represent their
views and it's a relatively small Harbor
we'll choose our attendees as per as per
the um the list there unless anybody's
got any strong feelings either way
um but I would ask for the harbor Wars
approval to get on with that please
thank you
members
it seems to me a logical and right and
proper thing that we should move on
yeah
the only comment I would make is that
bear in mind elected members face an
election in May
do you want to do it before May with the
one one of the ones or two of the ones
you've got now I'll wait for a new
Council
I'll take your advice on I you know I
have no idea is the answer I'd be guided
by you what you feel is the best answer
Peter
[Laughter]
well yeah I mean I think you're right
Bob that there's no point in sending
someone along who then the electorate
dispense with their services uh
I'd wait till after Maine to see who's
available really fine
okay
I'm as well understood I have to say the
Town Council do send someone along
um we do get reports back on the Town
Council occasion meal is what's going on
at the Estuary forum okay
well who are they whoever they were they
kept them themselves very quiet when
they said who they were
um I I was assiduous in writing down who
was attending but I didn't I didn't get
that so John you've got sorry you've got
your hand up Johnny
yeah I have yeah and I'm sort of
commanding you for attending that Forum
um and it just brings up another another
Point actually when we're looking at the
harbor accounts which includes your
salary and that of
um Kelly
I think what we've got to bear in mind
is that should the port close would
there be simply a free-for-all on the
river
I.E your jobs wouldn't exist or would
this job continue because I think we
need to consider that in the overall
picture
um for example Georgina in ilfracombe
has no commercial vessels apart from the
Oldenburg and she's supporting her job
and I think we've got a really you know
look at the actual cost of keeping the
port open and the realistic cost of
having the service
yeah it thanks Joe I thought you were
going to vote for a pay rise for us then
but um that was the next question
um there's two separate pits to this is
one is the statutory Harbor authority of
Biddeford as in the bit between the two
Bridges which is a commercial Port
um and disestablishing that as a port as
a commercial Port would require a a a a
harbor and a revision order or a
disestablishment order the separate part
of that is the pilotage area which
recovers from baggy point to Westward
hole at both estuaries um so I've got
two hats I've got a pilot's hat and a
harbor Masters hat if we disestablished
Biddeford which would be
I mean I think we'll agree the tragic
mistake and the wrong answer but
um it would require that that act
apartment to be revoked
um and uh this this will uh ebb and flow
last year was a bit of a slack year I
think hopefully we'll get on to that but
hopefully I I but thank you for your
vote support and I'll take the pay rise
well Paul what I'm trying to say is that
the reality is is that your roles are
essential whether it's a harbor or not
okay sorry I'm being deceased thank you
I agree
yeah
riches
are you going to agree with the payments
worthy enough no
um no just going back on to Mr putty's
point and and using ilford community
example I don't think we really can
compare the two the Two Harbors uh in
any way shape or form as as one off
against the other because primarily
Georgina's my understanding is with
ilfracum is it more of the Leisure with
the Stalls and the fishing boats and the
tourists that actually come specifically
to ilford pool Harbor there are more
sailings of the Oldenburg due to the
ties of from there so which is our main
source of income
um yes if we looked at which I don't
think is it would be a popular decision
um we wouldn't need as much resource in
into the harbor we were still cost the
authority
correct yeah
uh
Mr chairman if you're if you're happy
I'll take the uh I'll get on and get on
with the hug uh uh as an uh as read if
that's okay with you I'll get on with it
or do you want to vote drive on fine
very last uh you'll see the bit about
the round Britain e-rib
um that's coming sometime in the summer
um we're gonna put two car parking
charging points outside the office and
charge that when it comes and make it
suitable for us about it it's the right
thing to do it will we ever get
rechargeable electric boats coming
alongside in bidford probably not that's
why it's a car parking thing but um it's
a useful thing to say there's still a
port here in Biddeford come and look
what we're doing and that's why I
thought it was worth supporting
um I've got nothing else I know there's
two hands up
um but thank you very much I'm hoping
that next time I will have a slightly
more positive
um recorders to report on
okay whoever's got their hand up on the
go
okay it's me
um I see the Goliath has changed his
name presuming it's changed its
ownership and if so doesn't have any
implications for us
I wasn't aware that he changed his his
name he certainly hasn't changed
ownership
um
say again sorry this morning its name
was changed oh good lord uh I will find
out but as far as we're concerned it
doesn't make any difference in terms of
birthing or fees uh what it's called
it's still aimed by the same guy as far
as I'm aware but uh thank you for the
heads up I'll have a little poke on that
one okay
Peter yeah
um it's a question for Tom actually uh
Tom if you look at the introduction to
this report agenda item nine it says
confidential or exempt information not
for publication since we've been on
YouTube live for the last uh quarter of
an hour I don't know how does that apply
[Laughter]
um well pause the update it's not
normally a part two item it's not as if
no I think that's just an error on the
report that he's used
do you want me to get rid of that bit
for the next report please yeah I I will
do well picked up
um board that's all I have thank you
very much for your patience
thank you Paul
no more questions of all
right
next item on the agenda Tom uh date of
next meeting which is the 20th of April
and then finally any other business
right
20th of April you can all Diary aob any
other business
Peter
um yeah I I think uh Paul's asked I've
seen the letter you sent to Northern
Town Council about Moorings and so on
um you're asking there about the Ecuador
Harbor Master I think I can supply you
with some information on that at least
some history on it if you want it
any information Kelly and I are going
across the north Devon District Council
um uh Records in the next couple of
weeks just to dig out to try and find a
little bit of truth but any information
you've got greatly received it's all
useful background information to
actually understand what we're looking
at so yeah yes so yes please
thank you Peter
Doug oh thank you Bob
anyone else
if there are no other questions comments
or any other business
I'm going to declare the meeting closed
at 3 38 p.m well done good job